hello everyone and welcome to a really
awesome and short game from round two of
the uh meltwater champions chester
finals it's uh shakir mamidarov vs
magnus carlsen and uh well it it's a
game that features a really really cool
opening trap and someone falls for it so
uh without further ado let's check it
out uh with the white pieces opens with
d4 we have knight to f6 by magnus c uh c
for g6 knight to c3 and bishop to g7 uh
magnus goes for the king's indian
defense we have g3 momodaro prepares to
fianchetto his light square bishop and
c5 now striking in the center uh and the
mamidarova grabs this pawn you might
also consider knight to f3 advancing the
pawn to d5 but he has something prepared
for magnus so d captures on c5 and now
there is a game where knight today six
was played artemis defeated uh uh
makarian in a very nice game in 2020
with knight a6 but here uh we have queen
to a5 by magnus and it is now already as
of move five that we have a completely
new game so going after the c5 pawn
mommy thereof simply ca uh the fiance
was the light square bishop and queen
captures on c5 we have bishop to d2
offering the c4 pawn as well and magnus
grabs it and now rook to c1 so magnus is
feeling adventurous here uh and uh he
doesn't mind giving mamijarov a little
bit of development in but you have to be
careful if the queen and knight weren't
here that rook captures on c8 could be
deadly you might even get checkmated so
knight the a6 uh and now comes knight to
d5 okay the bishop is now defended so
the queen can move uh but where do you
move the queen to uh one might consider
something like knight to b5 but it's a
very awkward square for the queen knight
to c7 and you might run into a beautiful
royal triple fork uh okay for the moment
the knight on a6 is guarding that square
but it's uh it feels unnatural putting
the queen to b5 why why not just move it
somewhere else so magnus says all right
i'm going to continue playing this game
in the same style i'm going to grab
another pawn he plays queen captures an
a2 and now he runs just uh
where mamadaru wants him rook to a1
attacking the queen queen back to c4 and
now rook to a4 and this is now a problem
uh how do you continue here uh like we
mentioned the problem is knight to c7
check for the moment the c7 square is
guarded by the queen and by the knight
but uh that can very quickly change so
here magnus played queen to c5 and now
feel free to pause the video and try to
gain the winning advantage for
mamidyarov while i give you a couple of
seconds
uh so for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on realizing that
the defender of the c7 square has to be
removed but also that this bishop is
x-raying that rook on a8 so whoever
figured this out congratulations you are
an excellent um uh you know taker of
advices uh and for those of you who just
want to enjoy the show it is of course
knight captures on f6 we moved this with
tempo now the bishop's diagonal opens up
uh here we have bishop captures on f6
and now just rook captures on a6 that's
the good stuff and now
of course if the rook is captured then
uh mamadara will grab carlson's rook
kane but before we continue the game and
the game is basically over here this is
move 13 and yes magnus does have some
pawns but it is um
not not really compensation uh enough to
to
play against someone like momodaro but i
just want to point out that even if
magnus played the the best line of
defense and not bringing the queen to c5
but rather the b5 that kind of keeps an
eye on the knight here it still doesn't
matter we're still going to capture the
knight with the rook and now uh you
can't really recapture because if pawn
captures we deliver knight to c7 check
pick up the queen if queen captures we
still play that knight to c7 check pick
up the queen on a6 uh so not much you
can do here here you would have to
play something like knight captures on
d5 but now we simply play rook day five
ended when the queen moves the knight is
attacked twice so we would see some like
queen captures on b2 and now bishop
captures on d5 and this is the better
version of the end game that magnus
could have gotten if he if he played
this line as his pawn structure his uh
here is intact but uh as he played queen
to c5 instead and then this whole line
followed knight captures bishop captures
and rook captures an a6 now he gets a
bit of a different position
with doubled pawns here on the queen
side and since you're down a piece
that's a pretty big deal so bishop
captures an a8 bishop captures on b2 and
now knight to f3 mamidarov needs to
finish development we have castles
magnus um ready to develop the bishop
bring the rook into the game and the
castles by mamadiara we have d6 uh and
now bishop to h6 going after carlson's
rook rook to d8 and now bishop back to
e3 attacking the queen also putting
pressure on that a7 pawn so queen to b4
uh and now just bishop back to d5 we
have to bring our bishop um uh somewhere
useful uh we have e6 chasing the bishop
away but now not reacting to this
mamidorov just place queen to c2 with
the idea that if magnus captures the
bishop then we play rook to b1 and we're
going to win our piece back and but now
we've really missed a black spawn
structure and the only thing black
really uh has as a trump card sort of
maybe in this position are the pawns as
he is up three pawns but now with um the
double a and the double the d pawn
that's really not nothing to worry about
so instead after queen to c2 we have
queen to c3 right away uh here we have a
queen trade captures captures and now
again look to see one developing not
worrying about the bishop here so bishop
back to f6 and only now we move our
bishop so bishop to c6 we have a5
it's a past pawn but it's
very hard to imagine that you'll be able
to push this black has a bishop pair but
white has a bishop player and a knight
so here we have bishop to b5 and now
bishop to d7 offering a trade of bishop
so we have captures captures and now
rook to c6 now you have very nice
control of the sixth rank but also if
needed you can just put a rook on a6 to
put the pressure on the two pawns that
are well basically the only pawns that
can give you trouble for the rest of the
game we have d5 by magnus bishop the h6
now preparing rook to ca to check which
would force magnus to trade even further
so rook to d8 for the moment preventing
this and now finally rook to a6 and now
okay bishop to g7 magnus tries trading
off even more pieces so he can activate
captures captures and now rook captures
an a7 and now the a5 pawn will fall as
well
of course the magnus knows that this
position has been lost since move 13 but
you know
why not uh give your opponent a hard
time and make him work for his meal so
king to f6 we have rook captures on a5
we have rooked a d7 now e3 uh we have h5
by magnus and now we have rook to a8 and
now magnus plays rook to b7 there is no
plan he's just going to repeat moves and
uh well force uh mamadou to reveal his
plan so he starts activating the king
rook c7 by magnus h3 magnus repeats rook
b7 g4 we have captures captures and now
rook back to c7 we have g5 with check
king to f5 and now rook to a4 and now if
you're not careful rook to f4 will be
checkmate so we have to prevent this uh
e5 is played guarding the f4 square but
now rook to a6 going after rook to f6 so
how do you defend against this uh rook
to d7 uh you you you don't have to worry
about this check just yet because it's
not checkmate but uh at least you will
not be losing this pawn if something
like rook here comes and maybe you can
even start pushing your pawn who knows
so king to g3
and now king to e4 we have rook to a8
now trying to get behind the behind
enemy lines and rook to e7 otherwise if
you just play anything maybe rook here
and then it's just game over so rook to
e7 defending now rook to d8 you can't
keep an eye on everything you are down
piece so rook to e6 and now rook to d7
going after the f7 pawn uh we have f5 by
mommy darv uh by magnus and now mommy
are just plays e captures on f6 alpha
song uh and it was in this position on
mu 45 that magnus cross and resigned the
game as there is nothing more to be done
here for those of you who enjoy when i
finish games it's actually very simple
once the pawn is captured we just play
some like knight to d to check and
there's really not all that much this
pawn will now fall we can't prevent this
and if king d3 we can just capture it
king e2 and now even knight to e4
attacking the rook and you might even
run into a very nice checkmate for
example this pawn is hanging if you
defend it we just play knight to c3 with
chuck king e1 and rook to d1 mate so
this is one way to finish it another way
is that well okay maybe we don't capture
the rook maybe we play king to f uh the
pawn maybe we play king to f5 instead
and now if f7 we can play rook to f6 to
stop queening but now rook to e7 and
whatever you do rook captures an e5 will
be checkmate there's no good way to
counter this if you play something row
captures an e5 is checkmate and of
course if you try something like
blocking then we just bring a queen into
the game and you will get checkmated
very soon so of course magnus knows this
and after g captures on f6 alpha he
resigned the game
uh so 45 moves in this game but only the
first uh 11 are basically important up
until the moment magnus played c5 but
you can see how adventurous magnus was
in this game just capturing pawns here
here grabs c5 then he grabs c4 then he
grabs a2
and sometimes it's possible but if your
opponent knows what they're doing then
it's most certainly not possible
so that's the game hope you guys enjoyed
it and maybe you can use this trap in
your own games or avoid them if your
opponent tries to give you some free
pawns uh i would like to thank tom
deralon
joseph conrad and john sved for your
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot to really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
thank all for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
meltwater champions chester finals
checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day